[Music]
elephants ostriches and even a lion many
here are seeing these animals for the
first time in their lives it's great for
us kids to come to the zoo and see all
the wild animals before they do Cory is
a place that people that you know come
because of the insurgency there's a
reason that most of the people there are
not coming what I'm coming to because of
the fees does the reason that because of
the visit and come to that place to see
the animals and orders the zoo isn't mad
agouti
a city that has only been in the
headlines recently because of terrorism
the zoo is the only place in town where
you can relax and let your mind wander
entry has just ten cents the director
says the place suffered a lot when Boko
Haram were in control here at the peak
of all the troubles some of the animals
starve to death
out of desperation some of the zoo's
goats were sacrificed to feed the
crocodiles and lions
the previous government before this
governor the government did do was
negated even the pretty infrared the
government is good giving us an appeal
you know amount to give us to pede pede
animals but time God would this present
come and even last the previous years of
his realization yes that is giving us
pretty impressive so that was why we
have started killing in the cage and all
the place had become beauty we deleted
that we are getting from the camera the
director says the number of visitors
just keeps on growing he wants to make
sure they'll soon have even more animals
to see before the insurgency made uber
II used to be a flourishing regional
trade up a title the city tries to
reclaim although they are still frequent
bomb blasts and suicide attacks
especially in the suburbs may degree is
well on the way businesses reopens and
most people are optimistic about the
future of their hometown